being a writer of putting in those hours
of spending that time of building your
voice as a writer and to have conviction
as a writer
I believe you've referenced Dorothy
Parker many times where you say the
famous remark of hers I hate to write I
love having written you know we were
talking a little bit about her off
screen how do you relate to that quote
um well absolutely relate to that quote
um
writing is is hard
um it's um it's it's tough
for a couple of reasons there's two
sides of that coin that the actual
activity itself
um is
um is taxing and it requires a lot of
patience
and and also it is one of those um
chosen vocations where one is likely to
suffer a great deal of critique scrutiny
and attack
so
um all of that together makes it you
know makes it tough so you have to you
have to sort of build a sort of thick
skin now the with that comes the the
great myths of um of the writers and and
you know and all the all the the the
writers that um I can think of
um and this is across all genres of
writing
uh um most of them have this Aura of
strength and promotion promotion of that
strength as a writer and in their
writing
um and you know those and the finest
examples of it is Dorothy Parker is a
probably one of the one of the you know
the um the the Pinnacles of that of of
that idea of strength
um as well as someone you know of course
like Ernest Hemingway
um Hunter S Thompson James Baldwin
um all of these characters convey
strength and um
and that is a um is a quality
that comes from having to deal with the
rigors
of being a writer of putting in those
hours of spending that time of building
your voice as a writer and to have
conviction
as a writer
and and it also speaks to something a
little bit that we talked about just a
few minutes ago which was that the
character that you were referring to in
Michael Clayton and that is they don't
really fit in this box they don't fit in
that box
they kind of
there's not really a place for them but
they can't just fade away this is true
uh this is absolutely true I think that
that's a really that's an interesting
analogy and an interesting point that
you're bringing up
um
I think that
that once you go down the road
um
um as
is it um
I always get I'm thorough and Emerson
I'm confused but I believe it was
Thoreau
um the road not taken so to speak
um once you go down the road not taken
you know a friend of mine used to say
you know it's you know it gets a little
sketchy down there because the road not
taken is often patrolled by the cops
so
so uh once you go down that road don't
expect
um to not face adversity
you know
um
and don't expect it to not change you
don't expect to not
um
to not make you something that you don't
expect that you're going to be
you will you will more than likely
become smarter wiser you will you will
have survival skills that you probably
didn't expect that you would gain
but
it will turn you into something else
that's really interesting
For Better or Worse yes you're right I
like what you said how going down this
road that that's you know there's
there's not
um it's kind of a dark murky Road where
you're not really sure what's in the
shadows but it also is maybe sort of a
metaphor for what a lot of writers have
been maybe more alone or I know Outcast
is is not the right word but um they're
used to having to be their own strength
well I mean
to a degree I mean like
I I know a lot of writers and I've spent
a lot of time around writers this is a
whole other subject matter we can get
into this
in a bit
but
um
but um
being alone as a writer is not so bad
um because writers aren't really alone
it's a um
it's a
it's a kind of Illusion because writers
are
besieged with the often with especially
if they're writing stories they're
besieged with with characters that live
with them
so and it's it's it's this it's this
misnomer to say a writer is alone in
fact it's like writers
writers in a sense if you want to if you
want to call them you know anti-social
they aren't anti-social
um by you know I think by
um by Nature they're anti-social by
choice
because they just want to get back to
the people they know
[Laughter]
they're you're currently entertained
with
and
um and I think that um
I think that that's um really what it is
um
I I I think also conversely many writers
are extraordinarily gregarious
um
um my my personal Mo I think is that I
have two sides
um
and those two sides are I can be
incredibly quiet totally bashful really
shy
um a real introvert and then I swing way
to the other side and I can be
incredibly
um gregarious and extrovert and and
highly social and you know and loud and
boisterous and all those things I don't
know what that means
um
and
um but I do know that that it that is
not
um that is not something that is unusual
that that many many writers are fill
that mold